big picture little picture so I find
without repair that's one of the biggest
challenges is managing the big picture
the dream where you want to go with a
little picture of actually executing and
I find too many entrepreneurs are either
one or the other right you're the
dreamer you're the big picture of guy or
girl you know where you want to go you
know you know how you want to change the
world but you spend so much time
dreaming and thinking and not actually
executed in doing that you don't get
stuff done I didn't have the other
people who just work work work they're
constantly executing but they feel kind
of lost it feel like their work doesn't
have meaning because they're missing the
big picture and you got it you gotta
balance both right you gotta have the
big picture of where you want to go and
then actually execute against it to
build something meaningful and important
and the way I do it is I'll usually
segment that out to different days I'll
have a day where I'll be thinking big
picture planning where I want to go the
impact I want to have and then that'll
last me for a while of actually
executing right now in the next couple
of weeks or even a couple months
executing against that big vision that I
have and so how I apply it to my book is
when I first created the book and
thinking about it like what's the impact
I want to have right what am I gonna
call the book what's the change I want
to make in people's lives how am I gonna
lay up the chapters how am I gonna lay
out each page that flows well from the
next and then I got to the little
picture of actually writing the book
right not just come with an idea for the
book but actually executing against and
this has been a how many months I've
been writing it I don't know it's been a
while but it's exciting because you need
to have that big picture for what the
big book is gonna be and then the actual
execution against it on a weekly basis
creating the content so today is that
book running day I just got back from
vacation it's minus seven degrees
outside so I'm gonna I'm gonna stay home
and just huddle in and and create the
book usually I'm making as Vedas walk
into Whole Foods where I work on the
book and today I'm excited as the book
is pretty much done hooray hooray pretty
much done I'm really excited about that
and today what I'm doing is going
through all the copy and just making
sure that it flows making sure that it's
a big picture day today
making sure that all the little picture
days that I had although the execution
right
one page at a time at a time at a time
now all flows well together right I've
completed the project now gotta step up
and make sure that everything flows well
together and so it's an exciting day for
me and I'm also really hopeful that you
guys can take that knowledge and apply
it to your business where you have some
days you're thinking big picture and
planning and since it's New Year it's a
good time to playing think about where
you want to go I didn't actually spend
the time executing against that plan
until you feel maybe you know maybe you
feel a little bit lost maybe you feel
like you need to revisit the big picture
again but just don't get stuck on one
mode and not do the other don't get so
stuck on the big picture you don't
execute and get so stuck on execution
that you lose your way of where you're
trying to go and build a company so you
get to your questions first stop rishi
capti be there entrepreneurs and their
entrepreneur personalities do you think
aspiring entrepreneurs people who want
to entertain like say Mark Cuban or
those sharks on Shark Tank true pursue
entrepreneurship differently than an
entrepreneur who doesn't care for show
biz Thanks it's a great question and I
think Mark Cuban specifically has been
an interesting one because he's always
had that Flair he had this show called
the benefactor which I watched but
didn't last very long he did even make
it through its first season and it's
interesting to see now that he is a star
of shark tank and it also kind of shows
that if you stick with it long enough
your first attempts may fail they may
not work a lot people might have their
first TV show and it fails and like I'm
not doing that again
but Cuban kept on at it years later and
I was on shark tank and it's hitting it
large and so I love that little just
that little story as a lesson to
persevere and keep going but in terms of
the type of entreprenuer I think it's
easy to look at the guys who are the big
personalities to look at the Mark
Cuban's look at the Richard Branson to
look at the Donald Trump to look at the
Steve Jobs look at the guys who are
noisy the guys who are allowed the guys
who have strong power of the full
opinions and wanna be at the front and
you look at them and say well I need to
be like that to be successful where
that's not the case
what you need to do is is be like you
right you need to be the best version of
yourself and that may mean being a
personality if you are outgoing if you
like being on video if you like you know
you you you turn up when you're in front
of an audience or
the camera is on you then you should go
we'll all in on that right you should
try to do more of that because it's your
greatest asset and so you look at Cuban
and chump and Branson and those guys do
well because they've gone all-in on
their strengths but there's a lot of
people who are highly systems
entrepreneurs we've never heard of look
at the the Forbes billionaires list and
see how many people do actually
recognize their name you don't have to
be a personality to be able to be
successful I think if you try to be a
personality but you're not interested in
it if you think that that's what you
have to be to be a successful
entrepreneur then you're gonna fail
where if it's something that you're
genuinely interested in excited and
passionate about then you should do
because that's what makes you come alive
and that's probably a strength of yours
so it's really betting on your strengths
understanding what you're good at
understanding what you want to learn and
be the best in the world that and if
that happens to be personality great go
for it but if that's not a world that
you want to get into then don't feel
like you have to there are tons of ways
to staying and the best one for you is
the one that leverages your strengths
and passion the most
next up fanny M why do you only wear
black clothes fanny as you can clearly
see there are white drawstrings on this
sweater next up antwuan great video
again Evan Thank You Antoine about your
book do you already know if you'll be
translated into different languages I'm
not sure I haven't even really asked a
question to the publisher yet right now
I am just in book writing mode and
editing mode and getting something that
I can give off to the publisher this
week I have a call with them about
marketing what we're gonna do to get it
out there and get spread the word
believe that's Thursday I want to say
anyway all of these conversations will
be happening about languages about
audiobooks and all you guys have been
asking about that about the tour we're
gonna be stopping and so as soon as I
have info I promise I'm gonna share it I
appreciate the question and the love and
I hope so let me know what language you
wanted in and we'll see what I can do
next up Peter are you ever mad down you
always look so excited and happy of
course I'm mad of course I'm down
there's a lot of things that bother me
probably top the list is wasting time I
hate wasting time I hate feeling like
you know I Drive somewhere or fly
somewhere and it wasn't a good use of my
time
you know I ten
to not let it stick although there's
something in me that for good or bad I
just I forget about it I lock out a lot
of the negative things that have
happened in my life I try not to let
things impact me too much and maybe it's
because I'm all about belief I just I'm
optimistic I'm happy in general but I
don't wake up every day super excited
you know there are days that obviously
that that I'm a door on down but I tend
not to live there for too long I don't
know why you know maybe if I had a dumb
deep with self analysis or how-to had
some psychology done on me to kind of
ask me some questions I might be able to
figure it out I think she's my
personality and my value system I have
beliefs that I always think that
something positive is coming down so yes
of course
I get mad and I get angry and upset and
I get down but it tends not the lasts
too long
next up Frances very inspiring advice
Thank You Frances there are many ideas
that I've researched and taking action
on yet many people my environment do not
have the same interest you have any
advice on how to network with other
entrepreneurs around the area I've many
ideas that I know will make money after
exhausting hours of research but do not
know anyone with the same interest
desires to learn more really tough and
great question your environment is so
important that people around you are so
important you can't do this big thing
that you're trying to do on your own you
need help and if you don't already have
the network around you then part of your
job is to start to build it I would
start looking in two places one online
communities I've made an insane number
of connections online through my youtube
channel to Twitter people that I've
never met I've hired people that I've
never met I've worked on partnership
deals with people that I've never met
face to face and it's never been easier
to find communities of people who are
like-minded and can potentially work
with you on a project second is I'd be
looking at local communities I'd be
looking at whatever you're interested in
doing whatever if you're trying to
program something if you're interested
in marketing you're interested in self
tracking you know there there are meetup
groups there are programs or workshops
there are seminars that you should get
involved in right
you should be at these events at the
conference's at the speaking gigs
eventually I'd love to see you doing the
speaking right that's not to where I get
a lot of my connections now is from
doing talks at events and people come up
and find the afterwards to want to do
something together partly it's because
I'm not the most outgoing person
naturally I'm not the guy at those
networking events shaking hands and
talking to people so I create a
situation where people come to me and
that's by being a speaker at these
events so I would seek out events that
are interesting to you I would seek out
conferences and programs where you look
at the topic and like oh I want to learn
more about that and then you're gonna
find people at those events who feel the
same way and that starts the bond that
starts the connection I think if you're
a sole goal of going to an event this I
need to meet somebody here that's gonna
be my business partner you probably give
them get frustrated and not have a lot
of luck where if you are generally
interested in that topic that's being
covered and you want to go to learn
you'll probably meet other people who
are in the same boat who funny enough
then become your partners and become
great contacts for you for your business
so just start seek out events
conferences organizations online and
then offline communities as well to
start building up some connections good
luck next up margwa I have a question in
a brief I have a good job that I like
with a good salary but my family isn't
supporting me at all I mean some of my
family members that I have to deal with
daily are making fun of me and treat me
in a very bad way I can't even describe
it
what kind of do to succeed and be much
better financially and to feel better
that really sucks
not having people in your in your
environment that support you is is
really bad and especially when it's
family and when they're making fun of
you I'm not a family counselor and so I
mean I have the greatest advice for you
I think a couple things one you need to
first figure out you know are you living
your version of your life or somebody
else's version of your life are you
living the life that you want to live or
you live in the life that your your
family wants you to live and it's an
important distinction and once you
realize this applies to all haters all
people who doubt you all people who
laugh at you all people who try to give
you wisdom that you don't appreciate our
life is that person
have they done what you want to do have
they accomplished something that you
want to accomplish if they haven't and
if think I've nowhere close to it then
they're not in a position to judge you
you shouldn't be listening to them and
that trigger for me helped where people
who are making fun of me or people who
telling me that on what I'm doing is
crazy or stupid have they done anything
big have they done anything close to
what I'm trying to do and if not then
why am i listening to them why do their
opinions matter to me second thing is if
you're dealing with bullies of people
making fun of you just as a general rule
they thrive off of the reaction right
like kids who don't get enough attention
from their parents will then start
breaking things and acting out because
they want attention because negative
attention is better than no attention
the worst is being ignored and so part
of it for you maybe just ignoring that
part of it may just be not reacting
because they want the negative reaction
because they want you to freak out
because they want you to feel bad
because they want you to cry because
they want you to whatever it is right
and if you don't give them that
satisfaction if you just ignore them and
you don't let it get to you then they're
less likely to do it again they'll find
another outlet to find somebody else to
pick on so find some other way to get
attention it's another option and then
the third thing on this is I'm a firm
believer that you train people how to
treat you if you let people walk all
over you then they will where if you put
up the fences and you have high
standards and they're less likely to and
I reminded of a story of Nelson Mandela
was when he went to prison he made the
prison guards call him Sir think it was
Sir with some honorific title and how do
you do that he's a prisoner right he's a
prisoner and and his guards were forced
to call him Sir and he did it because
he's he carries himself in a certain way
he doesn't let people walk all over him
he doesn't let people mistreat him and
so you need to raise your standards you
need to raise your stance of what's
acceptable and what's no longer
acceptable and not staying for and
however you fight back and stand up for
yourself letting people know there's
anybody who's mistreating you in your
life anybody you
them do that you have let them talk to
you that way treat you that way and
until you raise your stains of what is
acceptable then it's gonna be hard for
things to change for you last stop jamak
you late excellent talk I often ask
myself there's practicing my guitar cell
hours a day count towards my business of
performing a play at a number of times a
week and that is a priority so in any
business you know you want to get better
something you gotta practice practice
practice practice practice practice
practice I've covered that before a lot
on the channel I think if you want to be
a performer then yes your skills that as
a guitarist will definitely help you
want to be able to play songs inside you
don't have to worry about trying to
memorize what what chords you're gonna
play and it's definitely a part of the
game but I think it's also only a part
of the game because being a performer
isn't just about playing the notes it's
about one not being nervous as in front
of a big crowd it's actually be able to
deliver on all the practices that you've
done when you're in front of a big
audience is about entertaining people
it's about having a message it's about
practicing you know what are you gonna
say when you get up on stage and so I
think the more you can make your
practice sessions feel like it's a real
event so as an example for public
speakers for me before before we get up
on stage I would practice a taco
practice it at home I would imagine that
I am talking to an audience I imagine
how we're gonna come on stage I imagine
what's the first thing I'm going to do
how am I gonna use my arms and body
language so it's not just practicing to
memorize in a speech it's the entire
delivery it's the performance and so I
think you should practice that as well
and so yes you want to practice your
chords and practice your songs and get
really good at the skill of playing the
guitar but if you want to be a performer
then practice being a performer so the
more you can get gigs great free gigs
unpaid gigs volunteer gigs whatever just
to get the practice and exposure
experience for you start building up a
following and to build that muscle and
then when you aren't practicing at home
I'd also say try to imagine that you're
performing in front of an audience you
are performing at Madison Square Garden
you know there's 40,000 people listening
to you what are you gonna do is you walk
onstage what's the first thing you're
gonna say
you're gonna hold your guitar are you
standing up or sitting down you know how
you're going to carry yourself is there
a message that you want to share with
the world besides just the tunes that
are coming out right all of that stuff
is important and the more you practice
it and the more you visualize it the
more real it becomes and then when that
moment happens and it does come you're
ready for it and you don't choke and so
I love that you're practicing keep on
doing it I just kind of raised the game
now to practice the bigger picture stuff
and not just a guitar the guitar is
important but it's part of the game so
thank you guys so much for watching I am
off to do my book I'm super excited
about it if you guys have a question for
me that you want in the next video
either about my book about the book
writing process or about something that
we've covered on today's episode leave
in the comments below and I'll have me
the next video thank you so much for
watching and continue to believe and
I'll see you soon